ladies and gentlemen this is a police
message if you're not exercising or
doing any essential shopping please go
home the message is clear but it seems
it's not getting through here in
Finsbury Park in North London Ignatius
like so many other people across the
country has defied the Prime Minister's
advice to stay at home he's bought his
92 year old mom out for a walk wide open
space it's hardly the House Secretary
has criticised people sunbathing in
parts and is warned that the government
will ban outdoor exercise if their
advice continues to be ignored
Beatrice doesn't have a garden so she
says she's had no choice but to come
here to practice her acrobatic
techniques I've actually been stuck at
home on my own for three weeks now
and I thought well it's the first day
there is really really nice and I
thought well if I go to do my exercise
my my hobby for now a couple of hours or
something and I'm going to my own issue
be alright whilst filming we saw police
issuing fines to those flouting social
distancing guidelines it will be
exercising outside that will be banned
or stopped and that would be a truly
horrendous face for all of us to be so
we have to focus on this small minority
of people who are just not doing the
right thing we are fast approaching what
experts believe is the peak of the virus
here in the UK so scenes like this will
be of some concern at a time when risks
shouldn't be taken as it stands the UK
hasn't seen strict measures imposed by
other European countries
but that could change while the number
of people gathering in parks across the
country has plummeted since a lockdown
was introduced though he's still using
them for exercise and recreation is
still higher than countries like Italy
Spain and France which have all seen
similar spikes in covert 19
related deaths the virus has reached
London's transport network five bus
drivers were among the latest to have
died in a capital their drivers union is
calling for transport workers to get
protective equipment many of our bus
workers live with dependents are ill
many of our bus workers themselves have
underlying health issues as well who are
risking their lives out there driving a
bunch so it's important that people out
there are using the buses to really
consider whether they need to use the
bus a lot while Hospital numbers have
fallen in some areas across the country
experts say the future of the virus is
in our hands no Philips Sky News North
London